let's go next to our caller from the
to10 area code caller from to10
what's your name where are you calling
from names Tony I'm calling from San
Antonio exists as you can probably tell
from the accent alright Tony what's on
your mind today I had a quick question
yeah I had a quick question
first of all just need to see if you saw
recently on the news that a but
Republicans just stormed the
congressional hearing no I didn't see
that okay so there's a large group of
Republicans that just stolen looking
directional hearing where the Pentagon
representatives is being questioned I
had a quick question that kind of
revolves around that and it's as this
goes forward with the impeachment
hearings and as we learn more and more
about issues that come this president
that's very turmoil based president
where do you see this evolving I guess
the best way is how violent is this
going to end up and what do you think
the overall the action is going to be
from the government moving forward the
reaction to what I just I'm not sure
Tony I'm understanding your question
the reaction of sorry I may have ported
that as I'm seeing it there's a lot more
Republicans that are saying they're
talking about a civil war and all that
and I'm sure it's all just bark and no
bite
but it's seeming more and more like it's
it's become more or less aggressive like
they are pushing back more than recive
Lee when it comes to investigations so
I'm kind of wondering what your take on
it is how far do you think it's going to
go and what the overall outcome is so
like
I think that basically this is just a
building of tension you have forces
investigating the president for a good
reason and then you have mostly
Republicans opposing it publicly even
though there are people like Anthony
scaramouche you who say that privately
there is actually a lot of disdain for
Donald Trump among the Republican Party
so I think that the tension will build
and Republicans will publicly push back
against the investigations as much as
they can and then it'll either get
pushed over one way or the other way it
will either become what some something
like what Anthony scaramouche II says
which is Republicans will eventually
have no choice but to just sort of give
up and say you know what yet Trump's
gotta go that this has to end at some
point or you will see that it looks that
as though Donald Trump is going to be
able to escape this unscathed at least
to the extent of removal we'll see what
the result of the November 20 2011
the Republicans who stayed with Trump
will sort of appear to be victorious and
and and at least claim to be on the
right side but it could go either way
it's really going to depend on public
opinion in the end okay yeah that's a
biggest question I had there I just
wanted to as far as living here and I'm
originally from a different southern
state but I grew up as a farmers kid and
kind of getting concerned as far as it
goes I don't know why someone anybody in
the south wants to support a silver
spoon fed kind of rich guy but you know
whatever I'm kind of concerned about my
family and their thoughts in their
process and I want to make sure
especially with the rumors of liberal
hunting parties which is ridiculous that
what people's overall aspect of the
outcome is I would like it not to evolve
into something I guess a violent I guess
the best way to put it in the overall of
it absolutely that's my view as well I
am against the violence Tony I
appreciate the call from San Antonio
I've got to move on I hope to hear from
you again